i don't need breakfast i'm not hungry
i've seen my blood sugar go way up in
the morning that's natural what happens
to me
from not eating not eating lots of blood
sugar it comes from my liver it's okay
making it that's what a lot of people
feel if you're not hungry at breakfast i
would say don't bother eating it okay
i try to skip lunch if i can i'm not
always able to because i'm stressed out
and i'm a stress eater but i try to skip
lunch
and then i'll eat a normal dinner
time restricted eating
cutting the window that you eat food
down to about six to eight hours a day
so is
will guarantee you that you will if
you're metabolic metabolically flexible
you'll start making ketones about eight
hours after your last meal
and by 12 hours after your last meal
you're
you're humming in ketones
but what's important and this was a
study of italian cyclists
what's important is you want to go
beyond just 12 hours eating and 12 hours
not eating you want to get to this sweet
spot
of about 16 hours of not eating that's
about an eight-hour eating window
and in italian athletes um and you know
you're a great athlete so
what they did is they took these guys
and put them on a training table for
three months and they all had to eat the
exact same food
the one group ate in a 12-hour window
they breakfast at eight o'clock they had
lunch at one o'clock and they had to
finish dinner at eight o'clock
the other group same food
their first meal was at one o'clock in
the afternoon that was break fast their
second meal was four o'clock in the
afternoon their third meal they had to
finish by eight so what's the same
calorie amount same calorie
schedule got it
when you look at the blue zones you look
at areas where people are living a
disproportionately long period of time
characteristics of each of those
populations some element of fasting and
protein restriction on certain days of
the week or at certain periods of time
during the year such as a religious fast
such as a daily or or weekly like one
day where you're not eating protein or
meat uh perhaps a certain period of time
each spring summer winter and fall or
you might go four to five days eating a
lower calorie diet or doing more of like
a cleanse or a detox but basically this
idea that
autophagy or cellular cleanup or fasting
is woven into culture as part of the
diet and so
women and men both
are capable of fasting and women will
hit the stress wall of fasting before
men do on average
and i love getting to talk with someone
who totally gets all the driving
analogies so the old expression of
hitting the wall we know where that
comes from right well
when you learn how to manage your
biology
and how to fast
without being hungry
what it does is it moves the wall very
far away so i have more resilience and
power and energy than i ever did before
that gives you time to build up speed
so you still can hit the wall and i i
teach for women that the fasting wall
when you over fast is about four to six
weeks i started off with the 16 hour
which i don't really recommend doing i
recommend now starting off with like a
12 hour just because that's a really
great way to ease into the process so
that you aren't shocking your system and
you're able to more strategically plan
out your meals you can actually get
enough of your nutrient needs during the
fast or during the eating window rather
that's a big problem with women that
i've seen is that they don't get enough
during their eating window and that's
what makes it unsustainable for them to
continue on with intermittent fasting
and why they get so hungry yeah i did
the 16 hour fast first and then i was
like oh my gosh i feel amazing if i feel
great with 16 hours probably like i'll
feel even better with 20 hours or like a
24 hour fast so i tried all those
and i made the mistakes that i now warn
people against where i didn't get enough
food for my body system because it's
really hard especially with protein to
get all those needs in during such short
window and especially if you're fasting
for a full day you can't really make up
your protein needs from that day with
alternate day fasting for example so
whenever you see like studies that are
talking about intermittent fasting not
being great for women they're always
talking about alternate day fasting or
extended fasting they're never talking
about time restricted feeding and if
they are it's when you're not getting
enough food for your body and so
periodic fasting has helped me keep my
weight down okay combined with exercise
you do this every day so the pure your
fasting goes every day right it's a
struggle is it a 16 8 split
yeah so i i try to do at least 16 up to
18 hours do you do the 24 20 and four
well i can't go for a whole day without
eating well it's 20 hours off four hours
on uh that might be what i do yeah on a
good day
um i can't do the three day thing so oh
three days of fasting yeah that's real
deep cleanse um and and by that i mean
at the cellular level there are there's
this process autophagy have you heard of
this so autophagy is the word that means
your cells are eating themselves what
they do is they they recycle protein as
energy source
and that doesn't happen
really deeply until after day three of
not eating
the only the shortened eating window
guys
they had the same athletic performance
but they lost weight the other guys
didn't lose any weight
and
one of these markers that i follow for
longevity insulin-like growth factor
igf-1
plummet plummeted in the shortened
window athletes didn't change a bit in
the other ones
so it was just the timing so in the book
it explains why that happened
ketones were being produced
for about four hours longer in the
shortened window athlete and what
ketones actually do
and that's why it's called unlocking the
keto code is ketones are actually
key
to making
mitochondria
protect themselves and to actually
become
inefficient at burning calories and it's
called uncoupling inefficiency
inefficient and that's how they lost
weight and it turns out
that
telling mitochondria
to
protect themselves
to make more of themselves get some more
guys to help out
and to actually waste calories is
actually how ketones work and it's it's
180 degrees opposed to
how we used to think ketones
made you lose weight and eventually you
get to this point where you know it
worked but now you're not feeling as
good
since it used to work you're going to do
it even more called the fasting trap and
it works with a vegan diet it works with
a keto diet it works with anything that
works at the right amount you go past
the goldilocks zone sure first sign bad
sleep so the way you would know that
your fasting wasn't working is you wake
up in the morning you feel like you're
hungover but you didn't drink anything
the night before and the second sign is
monthly irregularity in your cycle
right that's weird it's normally
predictable and now it's not
okay maybe you should actually eat a
little bit more or more often and the
third thing if you keep pushing yourself
and by the way people who might i don't
know drive race cars or be professional
athletes or be hardcore entrepreneurs
like the type a people we are the ones
who are going to push harder right and
then you say oh my hair is getting thin
and it's funny so that's the four to six
week i'm fasting too much thing for
women
but then for men it's kind of similar
but it takes us usually six to eight
weeks
and for men it's
sleep quality goes away and then
i'm waking up without a kickstand that's
weird and then the third thing is
my hair is thinning as well and and so
what we're doing here is we're saying
don't over train and as you know if you
exercise three hours a day every day you
start to not feel good same with fasting
so that's the big thing for women is
it's okay
to not fast the same way every day and
shorter fast
when you're already
having other stressors and longer fast
when you're not common sense
yeah
and you know more than most people about
the feeling of fear like you're in a car
it's going really fast okay and there's
a party that says i'm going to die and
then there's a party who says i know i
can put the brakes on half a second
later or whatever it is you do i mean
i've been on a track but not like you so
you know there's that that edge you play
with oh yeah it's the name of the game
right well we all have that edge around
food
right
and so oh my god i'm gonna die and it
actually it takes me 90 days to starve
to death but you sure feel like you're
gonna die i have a lot of problems with
the alternate day fasting i know there's
been some people have seen success with
it but not only do you not get enough of
your needs but it's so not sustainable
for life like how do you plan out your
life to be like okay on this day i'm not
going to fast on that day and but it's
it's john's birthday on that day and i
know we're going to be going out to eat
so am i just going to like have
sparkling water like it doesn't make
sense logistically long term and i think
that especially in the intermittent
fasting space it's so filled with these
like highly overachieving people where
they have the ability and the discipline
to like schedule out their life to an
alternate day fast vertical nine out of
10 people probably more than that can't
do that or don't want to do that and if
we're only preaching those methods then
we're not going to actually help
everyone else where you they could get
so many results with time restricted
feeding this is to improve your health
yeah so if you have
well it could be for religious reasons
but i think you'd only want to do it for
health
it's not
it's not fun no not at all